now you guys are going to be competing
head to head for that coveted title a
fortune fire champion and a check for
ten thousand dollars today in the Forge
we're gonna put a Twist on one of our
classic forgings competitions you guys
see you've got a cloth in front of you
why don't you go ahead and pull those
off for me you can make your blades out
of that big Suspension Bridge cable
between 13 and 15 inches your time
starts now
my name is Brian Dana custis I'm 41
years old when I was 14 years old I made
a screwdriver and as soon as I saw a
hammer hit hot metal it was never any
coming back
I'm looking at the two cables and I'm
thinking the big cable is going to be
easier to get a 13 to 15 inch blade I'm
twisting my cables I want to get it
twisted up as tight as I absolutely can
I've got to try to drive everything
together by smacking the Billet down on
the floor hoping that my welds will be
better
looks like it's compressing my material
just fine so I'm feeling pretty good
I think we got it
my name is Walter baronowski I'm the
fourth generation metal worker my
grandfather in the Philippines was a
bladesmith my father was a welder and
there was always like a deep calling I
started making knives when I was 18 and
haven't stopped since I probably don't
need all of these pieces so I'm gonna
pull two of them out I'm gonna work down
each one of these smaller pieces into
its own Billet make a stack boards weld
them together I keep looking at these
bars and I'm really telling myself dude
you don't have enough Steel
oh you may have them freaking out
I ain't got time to sit around and think
about what the heck I'm doing
I decided I'm gonna go with making
another bar
third bar made
[Music]
and I need to get these three bars Forge
welded together at this point I had zero
room for error Walter's way behind
you've got to start shaping a knife
right now the clock is ticking down and
I stick the blade into the forge just
try and please God get hot enough
going for a winch
Walter is shaking his head yes
singing like a canary with the file it
sounds good to me
my name is Paul DiStefano I'm 26 years
old and I'm an EMT for the New York City
Fire Department for me blade smithing is
purely an artistic Outlet I like blades
as forms of art because it's brutal but
it can also be elegant that's kind of
something you don't see often in other
forms of art I've made cable Damascus
before I'm trying to keep it thick so
that when I go over to the grinder I can
dig deep and carve out any bad welds
along the edge of the knife Chris cable
Damascus the outside is always going to
have bad weld no matter what so I want
to grind most of that away
I finally finished grinding I think my
welds look solid
now I have to try to hurry up and Forge
out the blade because I lost time
grinding I didn't quite get it to
everything I wanted but I'm happy with
the knife I finished for this round
Paul went in this is the right time to
be quenching I like it
I feel good
five four three two one placement turn
off your machines put down your work
this round is over all right guys you
can take a breath you're all making it
into round two of the competition we're
gonna ask you guys to add handles to
your blades making a fully functioning
weapons and that time starts now
my first objective in this round is to
get all that material ground off because
they told me it was too heavy
it's been about an hour at the grinder
and I'm realizing that it's time to move
on to my handle my plan is to put these
two pieces of wood together super glue
them just a little bit so that I can get
a hole through both slabs of wood at the
same time and keep everything lined up
I'm worried about spending too much time
on this I've got to move on to the next
step
I've done wire inlay before but not
quite under this sort of an extreme
circumstance I plan on using four pieces
of Twisted wire and laying them at
opposing angles like that
my Blade's looking good I started
setting myself up to make the knife
scales it's once they're cutting the
shape out right now bad move to me it's
a waste because he's going to have to
get up to that grinder and reshape those
once they're on anyway so you would have
wanted to see them glue them on the
handle itself if you're going to use
that technique
I just screwed up big time now he has
two right side scales he's gonna have to
redo it this is going to cost me some
time but I have to do it over
I just gotta relax accept what happened
and keep moving on
I've not done any kind of twisted or
braided wire like this on a handle
before but I need to make it happen fast
my plan of attacks is to run two strips
of the wire kind of on an angle inlaid
into the handle he's doing like a
three-quarter wrap so when the scales go
together the ends of the wire will be
between the tang and the scale I'm
running out of time I'm going into panic
mode so I glue the handle scales on and
I'm not going to sit around and wait for
everything to dry I'm gonna start
putting the finished Edge on this knife
the first thing I do I go over to the
handle material and try to find a big
block that I know will fit the width of
the handle that I forged
my hand isn't feeling good now I'm going
to focus on twisting up the wire the
easiest way to get a wire attached is
drill a hole where you're starting cut a
channel for it to sit in wrap it drill a
hole slide it all the way through the
handle material and glue it it wouldn't
go anywhere Paul's kind of gone down
that road that I was hoping you'd go
down
I think it's time to work on the blade
Edge
when I rock the blade back and forth
It's to create the convex Edge or an
apple seed Edge where it brings the edge
in so it's sharp but it leaves a little
bit of extra meat so it's a blade Edge
should be stronger my blade isn't as
pretty as I wanted it to be but I'm just
hoping that my Edge holds up to the horn
test
[Music]
down this round is over God man oh yeah
brother
late Spitz welcome to the strength test
the animal horn chop
to test the strength and durability of
your Edge as well as the overall
construction of your knives I'll be
chopping into these animal horns
remember this test is all about what
those horn Studio knives not what your
knives do to the horns Brian you're up
first you ready yes sir
oh Brian you took a lot of the weight
out of this blade and thank you very
much for that your Edge held up great
the handle is a is a bit small right
here I'm not getting a good grip on my
pointer finger where I really get a lot
of control but in all it's a strong
blade it's a good looking blade there's
a little bit of issue on the handle here
thank you very much
all right Walter can you hear your
heartbeat yet it's in my throat
I'm pretty nervous about this test
all right Walter this is a
is a cool knife I like this thing as for
the edge there is
one deflection right there a deflection
of the edge and also a delamination of
one of the wires of the cable so it's
kind of popped out and it's sharp if I
run my finger this way but the rest of
your Edge is still nice and sharp all in
all nice job thank you sir
all right Paul you're up you ready for
this
yeah yeah all right cool I'm not sure if
mags will hold up
all right Paul this is a chopper man
as it stands there's a little Edge
deflection right here you can you can
feel it you can hear it
moving back to your handle here the
contouring you have on this handle is
just a little too narrow in the front
here and in the back here but all in all
it's it's strong and it did really well
there you go
all right blade Smith this is the water
tube slice
to find out how sharp your edges are I
will take your knife try to cut through
these water tubes running up first you
ready for this absolutely
splashed in here
all right Brian let's talk about your
knife here it is a light and fast blade
and it cut cleanly that's one of the
cleanest Cuts we've had on water tubes
overall sir
it'll cut
thank you
Walter your turns are you ready let's do
this let's do this
all right Walter your Edge is sharp it's
got a clean cut through the water tubes
what I like about this is the balance is
right to be able to control this blade
overall sir
it'll cut dream come true here and you
say that
all right Paul your turn you ready ready
let's do this
all right Paul your Edge you're cut
cleanly on these water tubes
there is some weight to this blade but
it will cut it there you go
all right guys you all performed
extremely well and it came down to
extremely Minor Details somebody is not
going to be moving forward into round
three of the competition and that blade
Smith is
Paul Ben Abbott's going to tell you why
well Paul all of the blades out there
had either a handle issue or a blade
issue unfortunately yours had both
Paul you clearly put out a lot of effort
but it's time you leave the fourth floor
thanks guys
man I'm pretty disappointed I'm going
home but I'm going to keep at it keep
making knives
I came to try and win I didn't win so
I'm not particularly happy about it but
I had a fun time
thank you